en deuxième position va parler d'une
image concerne florence foresti elle
était interviewé en duplex dans
quotidien et elle a fait une allusion à
d'autres émissions ce soir chez ba ba je
veux dire après ce qui s'est passé à
regarder
[Musique]
excusez-moi j'ai fait un bon soir yann
qu'on sorte le mot était en réunion ou
raisonnée et bompas alors voilà je vous
attendais pas de sitôt non mais désolé
c'est nouveau on est peut-être un peu en
avance
stanhome installe toi je t'en prie un
nom je voulais bien que je t'attends
j'étais en train de regarder
voilà comme un de ces gentils comme tous
les soirs et très drôle et j'ai envoyé
un sms à florence qui m'a répondu m'a
dit on fait ce qu'on peut jeudi j'étais
très loin bayo ohu travailler et je
voulais dire bah y'a plein de gens je
crois qu'on est embrouillée ont brouillé
avec florence foresti ça se passe très
bien on s'entend très bien et j'espère
qu'un jour viendra nous voir florence
voilà qu à qui je fais un gros bisou et
je vous le dis voilà la réponse du
direct et je dis que c'était vraiment
très sympa et à quotidien et réagissent
bien is my way elle a quand même dit
c'est le chien qui a changé qui regarde
c'est vachement drôle et surtout des
rares actions quotidien j'ai bien aimé
qui se marre comme ça c'est vrai